hey everybody good morning it's Sunday
morning thanks for coming out here you
know this was sort of a short notice um
presentation I um sort of decided to do
it Friday as I was doing the uh earlier
presentation on the release of
orderflows Trader 7 and I thought it'd
be a good idea um once more people uh
started using orderflows Trader 7 to
sort of give him an A A groundwork of uh
you know what some of the new tools how
they can be used in various markets um
so you know I I I'm not going to keep
this very long today I'm going to try
and keep it short I'll try to keep it
under an hour um and just want to put
this out there up front if you hear me
coughing I apologize I'm uh coming down
with the uh I hope it's not covid um
there's a lot of Co going around now in
my kids school and in their soccer stuff
but
uh hopefully it's not that but if I
cough you know I I just need if if I
pause for a second and you don't hear
any sound it's cuz I'm drinking some
water so let's uh just jump right in I I
don't have anything really prepared you
know like any slid set for it because
you know you don't I don't think you
really need that um you know I had
talked about on Friday that I was going
to take a look at some different markets
you know I spent Friday the presentation
talking about e- minis showing all the
um tools on the e- minis but you know I
know a lot of you guys trade other
markets like the currencies uh bonds
crude oil so we're going to take a look
at those markets today okay let me just
get my notes out here real
quick flipping through some pages um
yeah and just really quick this is uh
being recorded um so you will get it on
the replay and we'll post it up on
YouTube as well um Lynn says the update
is awesome oh thanks I I appreciate that
feedback you know it's always nice to
hear from traders that uh you know get
value out of what we're offering in
terms of reading the order flow uh good
morning Alexander gour good morning
veto uh neon yep Jeff we are recording
Juan
um yeah I'm going to get into some of
the techniques with uh the order flows
Trader software Anthony Luciano good
morning guys Arman um
so okay now just really quick you know
when you first load the orderflows
trader software let me just this is
crude oil now this is an eight range
chart so I'll just show you here okay
when you load it right on your to your
chart
um the settings that come up right all
these defaults that you see in here are
sort of you know if your starting point
it's not what you have to
use okay so um and then the only ones
that are enabled are the Delta
Divergence
okay just go through here so you can see
Delta there's a little checkbox next to
each tool right it says enable right
align PC enable buy and selling TS
enable um so you'll see Delta Divergence
is enabled now I'll just turn it off
I'll turn off whatever I got turned on
here just to keep the starting point
clean um Prim Point controls I'll turn
off now the reason why the default
setting is set that way is because
that's what I use um as my starting
point for most markets then you know
depending on the market and the chart
type I will go and modify it
now the next question that I get a lot
is what's the best chart to use you know
is it a Time based chart is it a range
based chart is it you know a tick based
chart ranko chart Etc honestly it
doesn't matter you know really what
matters is your own style of trading
your risk uh parameters right your risk
profile so to speak you know are you
willing to take um more risk or less
risk you know for example okay this is
an eight range chart on crude oil okay
which I'm fine to trade i' I'd rather
trade by an eight range chart can crude
over a you know a one minute or
something like that but there's people
that you know want to trade a little bit
faster they're going to use you know
maybe a four or five range
chart and and some people you know maybe
say the volatility is a little too much
you know maybe when if we go up another
20 bucks and crude and trading over $100
um you know I might expand it because
the volatility you know as price goes up
so is the the range okay so um you know
if we go up another 20 bucks in crude I
don't think you know using an eight
range
chart would yield the same results in my
own analysis simply because because now
we're getting quicker moves because you
know now we're trading $100 and perfect
example is like e mini S&P right we're
trading you know over 5,000
now and I wouldn't use a four range
chart anymore that I used to use you
know seven eight years ago when we're
trading you know 19900 2000 so we've
doubled in price in the snps and you
know for me using a 4range chart is just
too much um so we'll start with crude
oil okay so crude oil eight range chart
again
don't get caught up so much on the chart
type you know whether it's a range based
chart or a tick based chart or a Time
based chart find a chart that works for
you and that more importantly puts the
order
flow in a format that's easy to read
Because all all all these numbers in
here you're seeing on the footprint that
is
just data right so you're trying to
analyze the
data as easily as possible right and and
so you know if you're using a 4 range
chart it might be too fast for you to
understand what's happening in the data
right if if using a Time based chart you
know you're constricted by time so as
you know as you get closer to the end of
the time period you know the bar is
pretty much formed whereas on a range
based chart you know bars are formed
based off of price movement okay
so crude oil okay now there there's a
lot of new tools I'll spend some time
mostly talking about the the newer tools
today but I'll mix in some of the older
tools as well so I'm going to talk about
crude oil I'll go into uh bonds and tens
Euro currencies and uh we'll take a look
at mini Dow later okay so you know it's
four or five contracts
um now all these tools that you see in
here right there's a
lot I do not suggest I do not recommend
mend that you add everything all at once
okay because if you do you're going to
get a lot on your chart and it's going
to be a lot to um try and make heads or
tails of right because again you know
more is not always better you know we
have the tools there because so many
people trade so many different markets
myself right I I trade markets that
99.9% of the Traders out there don't
even look at right palm oil in Malaysia
right and that's just a pet Market of
mine because I've traded that since
basically the 1990s right I spent a lot
of time in in Asia in Singapore and I
would travel up to the palm oil uh
places in Malaysia because I work for a
training company and there are certain
tools that I find work better in
agricultural markets than maybe the the
stock markets or you know the stock
indices so we'll talk about the new one
PLC wave right because this is a pretty
popular one um that I first wrote
about years
ago and I'm going to make one little
change here okay so the POC just so it's
a little easier to see I have the
opacity set at uh 50 I'm going to set it
or sorry at 20 I'll make it
50 so so it's a little easier for you to
see on the chart
now so you can see it's going to put
this box around where the PC wave comes
in right you see the green bar then the
red with the higher point of control red
with lower point of control just as here
right red with the green lower point of
control higher it's just simply a
pattern all right that that's all it is
it's nothing more than just a pattern
now you'll see like in an area like this
where Market is going sideways you often
get over and over right you see it's
coming coming in one you know it's
overlapping even here one two then
consecutive then one here and then it
breaks down you know going into the
close
now when you're looking at the POC wave
okay now there's a couple ways to do it
you'll notice there's
this red area drawn at the top of the
bar the green the Blue Area drawn at the
bottom of the
bar
and really what's that that's signaling
to you right that's an area where you
know if you're going to place a stop
that's where you would place your stop
right there at that area just below that
actually because this is where the wave
is taking place
now what some
Traders myself I've advocated in the
past about
is let's go to the setting um where are
we here P wave right there's a swing
filter okay right here enable swing
filter and that's going to be linked to
the global setting of Swing period okay
so when you do that it's going
to
show the POC waves right that are coming
in at swing highs or swing lows based
off of a particular period that you've
set okay so you're going to see you know
one here one here you know one here one
here and even back here right it cleaned
up a lot of that mess now
it is a global setting okay so if you're
using some of the other uh tools on here
for example you know um you know Delta
breakout or Delta Divergence with the
swing period it's going to be linked to
this swing period into the global
settings
um but if you really want to have sort
of you
know I'll say true swing highs or true
swing lows
um you can set it at a higher period
okay because the higher you go the
bigger swings it's going to look for
right five is pretty tight for most
Traders you know 10 would be another
level you I I would do like 5 10 20 mean
you could do 510 15 but you know 5 1020
um and go from there now you so you're
going to see right this one's still
there that one is there um you have the
one here just sort of went sideways here
just sort of went sideways you here
here here here
here now on a range-based chart okay
this is one of the differences of a
range based chart versus a Time based
chart is I'm always a big believer in
what I call the trade entry signal you
know I have this programmed into a lot
of our individual tools um and really
what it is it's let the market take you
in to a position okay okay and so
basically right you see the the blue box
here in the
middle okay so this is the low of the
the wave this is the high of the
wave what you want is a breakout Above
This high right so you know the market
is going now in a Range based chart
you're always going to get that period
sometimes it's going to go you know you
might just go two ticks like here and
then go back in um on a timebase chart
right obviously it's formed different
and you're going to get a lot of bars
that you got the high of the wave and
then you go inside for a while right you
don't get that initial sort of breakout
so if I were to change this
to a one minute
chart all right let's
see this a little
smaller go back so like here's a a
bullish wave but obviously we never get
above the high of that bar um
here's a bearish wave right next bar
goes inside and then you start breaking
down a little bit and you get a little
bit of a move
down let's go back excuse me you again
bullish wave inside inside and then you
break out and go higher here bullish
wave one tick higher pull back in then
you start moving that's sort of the
difference that you know depending on
the chart type you're using
you got to keep that in mind because you
know if a trade if the market goes
inside on you in the next
bar then you're sort of not getting that
initial let's let's go back here right
you're not getting that follow through
right it doesn't come until three bars
later so really you you want to see the
market moving in your direction because
you know really with the wave is you're
trading a breakout right because what's
happening is you can see here right the
point of control on this red bar right
it's even align point of control with
the previous bar then you start trading
lower right and volume is going lower
then it sort of spins around I say it
spins around but it puts in the heavier
volume at a lower
level and often what's happening is you
know there there's passive buyers in
here absorbing whatever aggressive
selling is taking place aggressive
selling dries up then it's aggressive
buying and you move higher and you put
in a higher point of control so now you
know volume bar one is kind of neutral
you go a little bit lower volume is
starting to go down price went down
volume went down but It reversed right
and then It reversed into um the next
bar and volume starts going higher right
the same would be true on the opposite
side on a on a red candle setup on a
bearish
setup but you still need that order flow
to be bullish and in this case it's took
one two hours before it popped out here
and you know went up about 20 ticks
there
now if you
again if you're on a you know the the
range based
chart okay right every bar every next
bar is a breakout of the previous bar
right because that's why it's a range
based chart right because price is
moving based off of range so you're not
going to run into that that's sort of
one of the little nuances if you're
using a Time based chart or um you know
a range based chart so that's the the PC
W but quickly I want to talk about
um one of the older settings Market uh
weakness I'll turn off
the
wave Market weakness
okay and I'm going to use a swing filter
I'll set it back to five I mean I could
keep it 10 but I'll just make it five
for
now because before we didn't have
um the market weakness
with you know a look back period it was
just going to come in anywhere there was
Market weakness like here or you know or
here
now what we found is if you're using a
look back period you could actually
modify it
slightly from three into
two okay and again whether you want to
use five or 10
right it's again it's a global swing
period so if you're using the swing
period on other things it's going to
affect that as well but we'll just keep
it at
five okay so you can see again here here
this is a bearish one this a bullish one
but it's going to capture more of the
major swings so again you know a look
back of five will give you it'll be a
little quicker to trade
um you know here to
here here none here right here so and
again if
uh you're using a a higher look back it
would you know if I was using a look
back of say 10 all right this wouldn't
show up this one probably would um it
would just filter out a few of
them okay
so again if you're depending on the type
of chart you're using that's a range
based chart you know on a minute base
chart there there's
one you know here just went
sideways here but again you know with
anything you know with any
orderflow analysis let the market take
you in okay here you get your signal of
a bullish Market weakness and it's
coming in it's going to start printing
as as soon as you know it's showing in
the order flow and you just wait or you
just wait you drop a buy stop in you
know a couple ticks higher than the high
of this bar to get long that's where
you're going to get long just as here
you wouldn't short this one are you
going to say well that's a failed one
well yeah I mean it's set up in the
order flow
as potentially failing right you can see
how the Deltas are are getting weaker
right 80 you know 65 84
5412 okay which generally should be a
potential short even got like a bearish
paret point of control up here you got
some heavy volume but the next bar
doesn't go any lower there was still
more buying to come
in at that time that's why I say you
know all you'd have to do right you just
You See This Bar forming here
okay and you know with a Time based
chart it's a little easier because you
could add a bar timer right on here on
indicators ninja Trader has a bar
timer you just scroll down here bar
timer click on it and it's going to
appear down here on the bottom obviously
the Market's closed so you can see you
know but if the market was open you it
would be printing you like just counting
down how much time is left for that bar
to
form so you know if I'm down to 10
seconds and I see the market trading
okay I just drop in
a sell stop right here if we break down
here yeah I'd want to be short just as
this one if I see the market you know
there's 10 seconds left in the bar yeah
then I just drop in a buy stop you know
one or two ticks higher from where the
current high is and let the market take
me in you know get in at 65
thereabouts you know it goes all the way
up to you know
85 before it finally breaks down but
again you know that's you know like here
perfect example it doesn't go any
lower aggressive buying on this way up
is slowing down right and you know
because you got to think about what's
happening in moves in the market right
as the market is going up you have a lot
of aggressive buying but eventually that
aggressive buying starts slowing down
people start thinking you know people
that were long from
earlier you know they're getting long
down here they see it going up then they
see you know it starts going sideways
they start selling right they start
taking profits not everyone's going to
get long from here and get out up here
it doesn't work that way you know along
the way people are getting in and
getting out of positions so you know
that's why sometimes you see that pause
right you see this move going up then it
pauses go sideways right one two inside
bar inside bar then it continues right
because could very easily continue which
it did or go sideways then break down
right we don't know until what we see in
the order flow with the other Traders
what they are
doing okay so that's just uh you know
something
that you want might want to consider um
especially with you know now we have
that swing filter the swing period right
five um for
Market weakness if you're using Market
weakness you know try it with the swing
filter and set the sequence length a
little bit lower and just you know
really quick you know a lot of the tools
you know you could test them with
exhaustion prints
um you know depending on what you use as
your if you use exhaustion prints your
your volume limit you know set to nine
but if you want to set it to you know uh
a lower number
three you could do that looking for
exhaustion at swing highs I don't know
if there was any here and any of these
well three is probably a little too
tight let's take a look on the eight
range
chart yeah three is just a little too
tight well there's here's a one here's a
two okay you know you buy the one here
goes up a little bit fails fine two here
just shoots up from 50
excuse me it's a $1 move right here 7950
to
8050 a little failure here failure here
but again on a range based chart you're
always going to get that initial Market
moving in One Direction so you know
because this bar formed and it's range
based so for the next bar to form it's
got to tick take out the high by at
least a tick for the next bar to form so
maybe on a range based chart you might
want to use two ticks or something you
know here was a short here was a long
but again you know it just gives you an
idea of how you can start to use these
tools that are there again I'm not
saying that you got to use five you know
if you use you know if you were to keep
the exhaustion print at
nine you
know who knows I haven't even looked at
that but um you know here's nine right
catches this move here catches this move
here not much of a move here but from
here to here back up
um here's a nice move
down another little move but you going
to get those small moves like that so
maybe you know maybe you want to set a
higher swing period you could play
around with it that's the whole point of
it it's not for me to sit here and say
this is what you have to use in this
market on this chart type it's about me
explaining what how you can use this to
build your own trading um plan right
your own setups on what you're going to
look for in the market so let's uh let's
let's shift
to um bonds or tens we we talk about
tens since that came up on Friday's uh
Friday's call again I'll just go back
from the original
setting and I'll talk about some of
these settings and what I look for
in you again it's not that
this is what you have to use in this
market okay because you can play around
with it in all markets okay so this is
the default settings okay and you know
for you guys that have watched my
training videos the weekly training
videos or you know attending the live
sessions you know there's certain things
that I I really like to look for okay
this and get the crosshairs up
here you know the bearish pr point of
control with the um Pro the bearish pr
point of control that's not traded into
and you know the value area that's not
traded into in the next bar we got a
Divergence and a ratio as well so let me
just clear off some of this stuff here
because I want to talk about some of the
newer setting um I'm going
to change this here swing
filter on the the Divergence I'm going
to take it off only at the high or the
low again it's going to be linked now to
a period of five and just as not to
confuse anyone with the pro I'll just
disable the Primo controls really quick
and I'm going to disable the value
areas so basically going be a slightly
cleaner chart in the sense of uh now I'm
looking
at
Divergence Delta
Divergence at swing
highs and swing lows okay so you see
here right this gold area gold
gold all right gold
gold gold gold gold gold
now one thing that I've
always one
of you know people always ask me what's
your favorite trade setup I don't have a
favorite trade setup I sort of have a
group of setups that I like to use and
one that I've always talked
about was as long as I've released the
software is the ratio and Divergence the
bearish ratio bearish
Divergence
now there is a swing filter here as well
for the ratios okay and again it's also
linked to the global swing
period And so let's go back to the ratio
where are we here what I'm going to do
is I'm going to make the draw mode fixed
or sorry from fixed I'm going to go
until tested okay I'm going to keep the
ratios the same 30 and
69 and with the ratio and Divergence
setup if
the well actually what I should have
done is uh
it doesn't really matter but
um just go back here I'll just keep it
here because I just realized if
you let me just turn that off I'll turn
off the swing period um with the ratio
and
Divergence if you have the ratio coming
a bar after the Divergence because
historically right in the past i' only
look at divergences at highs or lows
swing highs swing
lows and what I found is it's just as
effective if the Divergence comes in at
a swing high and swing low and then the
next
bar has the
um has the ratio okay oh one other
thing you'll see on the settings right
orderflow ratio Zone size is set to zero
okay it's set to zero so when it's fixed
right it's just going to show on the bar
it's not going to show any colors
however if you're going to make it until
tested all right you got to change that
from zero to one so if it was fixed I'll
show you okay we have it set to zero
here overflow ratio Zone
size um so you could see right it's just
112.5 if it was set to
one that area where it's written up
there would be a red color or blue color
if it was bullet
so right I'll set it to one just to show
you the
difference so if it was set to one right
you can see it's red you know the
bullish ones are going to be um blue
blue blue
okay but if so if you're going to draw
it out fixed this can't be zero it's got
to be at least one or sorry so if you
want to draw it out until
tested here
we here it's got to be a value of more
than zero it's got to be like one
doesn't have to be anything else as long
as it's minimum of
one okay
so here so it's going to be a little bit
easier to see so what I'd be looking for
are these areas here you know this one
well it's 9 o' this is also 9 o'cl where
you have the ratio and the Divergence
here and here in the bar so you're going
to get the the red on top of the gold
color
or you know the
blue below the gold color okay that is
one of the setups that I've always
looked for for a decade okay and
now with
the
um you know the swing filter for looking
at Del divergences you know on an
intraday basis you know I can take a
trade like this here
because I got the Divergence followed by
the
ratio okay but it's got to come in the
bar right afterwards so that's you know
that's depends if it was bonds if there
was one there was one here okay because
again if I'm looking at divergences at
highs or lows of the day I'm not going
to get this trade
here right there's one here at 4: in the
morning morning one at 3 in the
morning you know this one that was the
low of the day but it came in the ratio
came in in the bar
afterwards okay there was one
here but that's you know one of how you
can use um some of the existing tools
the ratios and Divergence now let me
talk about the orderflow gaps here now
let me just clean this up I'll turn off
the diverg
and I'm going to turn off the
ratios I got stacked in balanced I'll
turn that one off uh okay so ratios I'll
just disable
that now gaps okay I'm going make it a
little darker because it's set at 20 but
I'll just make
it 60 so you can see it a little bit
easier on my chart now you can obviously
you could enable a swing
filter if you want you could also um
draw out the gaps fixed or until tested
right you see the Zone size is one so I
don't have to worry about whether it's
going to appear or not we start out with
it first without the swing filter okay
so you can
see here now now this is bonds okay 10
years are going to look pretty similar
right so you see on this move up Gap Gap
Gap Gap gap on the move down Gap Gap if
it was looking at 10
years right you know kind of similar you
know Gap here up up gap down Gap Gap Gap
Gap Gap you don't need to use a lot of
the other tools right if you're looking
at something like that now you can but
obviously remember the more you put on
your chart you know the Messier it's
going to get so if I were to put on
things like um you know Delta
Divergence um you know exhaustion
prints uh you know I'm just choosing a
few
here you know you even open point of
controls um you know if I were just
adding a few more things
here it might get a little confusing for
you right because your head's going to
start to spin thinking oh you know hey
this one's got a gap and but this gap's
got a exhaustion print or you know this
one you know even if I had Point
Prominent Point of controls on here it'd
be lit up on this chart try and keep it
as simple as possible for things that
you want to look at okay again it's not
about adding everything all at once it's
not about making it um you think of this
as your Buffet line you know all the
indicators that's your Buffet line
you're going to pick what you want you
know maybe this one is crab legs to you
or this one is the brussel sprouts that
you don't like to use so you don't have
to use it um so keep the gaps there okay
so
now another thing you maybe you might
want to use on the gaps is the swing
filter people might say well you know
this is too many too many signals for me
I can't trade that okay it depends on
the type of Trader you are right I know
guys that trade
tens they're just looking for a signal
that they know is reliable and they just
plow right in because they don't on 10
years they can move a lot of size and
they're just trying to grab a few
ticks out of the 10 years but um if you
want to sort of filter it down throwing
in the swing
filter looking at swing highs and swing
lows what I got it set I think I set at
yeah so it's set at
five I mean look at that if you only had
one trade this day along from here to a
short from up here even if this was your
only trade this day this short you know
here in the morning 3 in the morning
here two up here okay you take this
short you get stopped out fine this
short runs in your direction this one
just sort of goes sideways this one runs
this one fails and goes down then turns
around goes back up that's with the
swing filter now one thing to keep in
mind again with a gap right an orderflow
Gap it's going to measure sort of this
gap between the first bar and the second
bar so as the second bar is forming the
Gap can appear but it's not going to be
confirmed
Med until the bar closes because
obviously if this bar is still trading
things can change it can turn around in
the bar and close that
Gap then it would
obviously no longer be there okay
so people always talk about confirmation
what is the confirmation well the second
bar so you got bar one bar two second
bar has to close once it closes once
that Gap appears it's not going to going
to disappear it's there okay that's
that's how it is right just says this is
bar one this is bar two now if we're
trading down here right we know this is
a range based chart and we're trading
down here at the
bottom then there's a high probability
it's probably going to close it's you
know it does happen once in a while
where you do get like that big wick
candle down sort of like this right this
bar opened up here traded down it's a
red candle red candle then reversed and
closed up
but you know on Range based charts it
mostly just runs um but even this next
candle it was green for a while because
it's trading up here here then it turned
around and went down but for this Gap to
be confirmed the second bar because it's
gap between bar one and bar two it has
to
close for The Gap to be confirmed so
just bear that in mind because if you
were
well let's put this is 10 so let's SP a
5 minute chart really
quick okay so for example right if I'm
looking at a FIV minute chart now it's a
FIV minute chart on
10 right we know tens you know minute
based charts obviously move much
different than range based
charts so like this
Gap at 4 minutes 59 seconds is about to
be confirmed right then boom in five
minutes it's
confirmed
okay whereas on the Range based
chart it's confirmed once the new Bar
opens okay so the bar has to close all
right just as here on a five minute
chart five minutes have to trade for
this Gap to be confirmed but again at
four minutes and 50 seconds you got a
good feeling that it probably is going
to be um confirmed you know if it was if
you're on
a you
know just really quick looking at a one
minute chart you know intense is is
going to be very difficult you're not
going to see anything but it's going to
be hard to analyze the orderflow
sometimes just because it's just
trades like this you know one or two
price levels but if this was
say
uh like like a euro currency
okay I'm going talk about Euro currency
next okay so like here's a gap that was
formed right again this is on a one
minute chart
so once this bar closes this Gap is
confirmed right then the next bar goes
inside then you sort of break out a
little bit um you know just as here but
again if you're using any of these
orderfill tools let the market take you
in because if you get a signal right
some sort of bearish signal you want to
start breaking down you don't want to go
inside right like you're doing here
right you want what you want is okay I
got my signal then the next bar starts
trading lower right to cap capture that
move right why you want to get short and
say oh I got a gap here and when you get
short immediately on the open of the
next bar then it trades higher and
eventually stops you out you don't want
to take those trades you want to take
the trades that are where the market is
moving in your direction okay if you
know this was an eight range chart I
talk about crude next or sorry talk
about the currencies next right you can
see here okay again that's at 9:00 or
just before 9 here but you know 5
minutes
after the market moving information came
out on Friday right here you got a nice
move here nice move down here again
range based chart
so you got the two red bars and then
this next bar just goes lower by it two
ticks trades back up before it comes
back down this is what happens on Range
based charts you're always going to get
the break down or break up
in the next bar by at least one tick
generally you know sometimes you know
it's range bases just does this to you
two ticks you if you're on a four range
or five range could be one
tick
um now okay let's go back to
uh go back to tens real quick the other
one I want to talk about again it
doesn't matter what Market you're
looking at
um with these you can
use all these setups in any Market that
you're looking at okay so that was the
um those the
gaps so take that off now next one I
like to use is the open point of
control and this one okay so you'll see
these point of controls are colored it's
bullish it's dark blue if it's bearish
it's this kind of this purple color and
it's kind of dark okay it's dark for a
point the point being if you're using so
here right magenta set at 50 because if
you're using the uh Prominent Point of
controls we also use
magenta but the opacity is set at 20
okay
now one of the main differences between
this open point of control and Prominent
Point of control is it'd be extremely
rare to get an open point of control and
a Prominent Point of control in the same
bar um but anyway basically all it's
looking at open point of control is
volume migrating higher as price is
going
higher okay so there's a look back this
one has its own
individual look back
setting just go here take a look here
right so it's it's not linked
to it's not linked to the global setting
up here right it's down
here it's in look back bars it's called
so what it's doing is he looking over
the past bars making sure the point of
control is higher that's it it's not
some secret algo right because what's
happening is often times this Market is
going sideways here you see these one
two three
bars now it's starting to break out
okay is volume following it higher
or not period that's what you want to
see and how how can we use the order
flow that for that is simple use the
point of control that's the price level
in the bar with the most volume so if we
know that that price level if we know
that that point of control is migrating
higher then we got a fairly good idea
that price is going higher volume is
going higher and if we know volume is
going higher together with price we know
it's generally going to be a healthy
move move right to the upside just as
if volume is going down and price is
going down people say wow does it really
have to do that what it should right and
and you can see how as The Market's
moving higher the volume is also moving
higher I mean it's a simple thing
honestly it's you know I mean in the old
days right people used to look at volume
um this way I'll show you
right people used to look at volume down
here okay they' be like this bar is a
little bit higher this bar is a little
bit higher this bar is a little bit
higher so we know it's a healthy move
okay well why not just look at the
volume where it's trading in the bar is
it also going higher right save your
eyes from having a squint is this one
Higher Than This One yeah it is like
that um you know basically that's what
you want to see all
right we going say well this volume
didn't go higher here the volume is
actually going lower but in the bar the
volume
itself relative because now it's
relative right because if you're looking
at volume here here right the volume
that's being traded in the
bar well this Bar's got 26 ,000
contracts traded but the previous bars
got 36,000 previous bars got 36,000
previous bars got 52,000 but within that
bar the volume
itself the heaviest volume in that bar
even though it traded 26,000 which is
10,000 less than the previous bar is
still moving higher so overall that
volume is moving
higher higher than the previous bars
highs okay now
I've always been a sort of a fan of what
what I call the abandoned or the not
traded back into you know I don't like
to use the word virgin because it's got
you know people oh he's talking about
sex or something but virgin in the sense
that hasn't been traded back into right
or that's why I use the term abandon and
when I see a point of control an open
point of control that's not traded back
into in the next bar to me that's
usually a pretty high percentage trade
you can see here here here or here here
there's one
here one here one here and you know if
you're looking at you any other market
right you still look for the same thing
now this is a four
range chart so it's going to move a
little bit faster but you know you know
there was a bearish one but you got a
bullish one here you know if you're
trading a four range chart this is Euro
currency obviously it's going to move
faster I
don't really recommend people to use a 4
range chart
unless they're
convinced that they can get in and out
of a position quickly as opposed to ah I
want to give it another bar or two um to
trade or if you're on a you know even if
you're on a a Time based
chart
right the abandoned one here
here here here
here you know on this way up well here
we went
lower but here right on this move down
again it's got to be trading below it
right if it's red should be trading
below if it's blue you want to be
trading above it okay don't be like oh I
got a blue abandon Prim point of uh open
point of control trading below it I'm
still going to get long right no you
should be trading above it if it's
abandoned and it's blue should be
trading above not
below um okay so let's say I talked I
got bonds I got euro currency talk about
mini do for a second here I I don't want
to talk about e minis I spent two hours
on E minis the other day so I'll talk
about uh or mini da
now this is again the default settings
that's set up here so I'm going to just
disable the stuff so not to confuse you
guys on what I want to talk about
now turn off the
ratios Point
controls
stacked
imbalances value areas I could keep I
can keep a lot of these on but I just
don't want to you to get confused by
seeing other things and start thinking
something different okay so this is my
chart now mini da okay
on a minute based chart it trades a lot
of prices you see this bar here it's
almost I mean this is obviously was
9:00 um it's a 100 Point move okay These
Bars here it's about 30 point move 30
point move you know here's about 50
point move you know on markets that are
like that like mini
da um M andq and
Q what I found from talking to Traders
is they prefer to use range based charts
it's a little bit more
consistent um as opposed to
a you know a chart where you don't know
if a bar is going to you get stopped out
within the bar immediately um but again
it's just a personal choice so you can
see here right it's a little more
consistent um we're trading quite High
almost 40,000 so you know 10 points or
or even 15
point or 15 range um bar again it
doesn't matter just find the one that
makes sense to you I wouldn't use an
eight range chart in this market I would
definitely use something um stronger now
I'm going to talk about is accumulation
distribution
okay accumulation
distribution now I should have just had
my Trader program the passive Traders
and control part because if if you're
just not using it with passive traders
in control you're going to see a lot of
signals
okay right here like almost every other
bar has got a signal so if you're doing
that that's just showing some signs of
accumulation distribution so actually
it's not that bad right because you if
you can determine that hey you know what
I've hit a swing low starting to rally
and I see signs of accumulation coming
in you you would ride that up right but
it gets confusing sometimes in thinner
markets and I'll show you a market like
bonds later They are thicker
um you know it could be a bit
overwhelming
but the sort of the one that puts it on
turbocharge in my opinion is the passive
traders in control so it's not just a
sign of accumulation or distribution but
you know the passive Traders really
being in control you know here here so
it's taken out some of the poor signals
you got you could write it from here up
to here here up to here you know then
sideways activity catch the major Trends
now another thing that you can do right
that
is add on the swing
filter all right so it's giving you the
swing low this to the swing
high right here well this is
9:00 you know a move like this you know
here to here I don't know if there's any
signals here this is the night
before but you said get the idea right
of how again this
is
in mini da okay you see here nice little
move here so it's going to be on the bar
itself so just as soon as the next bar
starts you know as soon as this bar
closes the next Bar opens it starts
training above that's your sign to get
long you know from I don't know 10
all the way up to 5050 60 it's a 50
point move there and there'll be on
where sort of gives you this head fake
here and then comes
down that's the difference with the
range based chart um if it was a a
minute based chart again you have to
draw that line yeah you have to make
that conscious decision do I want to
trade a range based chart
or a minute based chart you know a
minute based chart or a range based
chart okay because the way you your
setup are going to look it's going to be
different right you don't see as many
here on the minute base chart if you're
on
say let's go to
tens now if it was a market like tens
again I can't use a minute base chart
there just because it doesn't have
enough movement in the one minute period
um I on a market like 10 that trade a
lot or any Mark you know interest 10
bonds I'd be hesitant to use the swing
filter simply because there's going to
be you know I know this Market trades a
lot of
size um and and I know how it trades you
know it trades against the whole curve
right and not only the
curve you know tends against bonds
against Ultras against um fives but also
trades against the European market it's
right the
buns buns is a 10-year contract the
guilts um so there's there's a lot of
other stuff going but if I can identify
areas where there's accumulation taking
place here here you know it's going give
me a in my opinion it's going to give me
that Advantage right people say well
what about the night session you know
can you trade this at night well of
course because look at the volumes
strong volumes European session there's
a lot of Arbitrage that goes on right
there's a lot of
these old say um prop firms these
Pioneer prop firms where guys are just
sitting there at night well now they got
it all programmed to trade tens against
bonds or tens against buns rather tends
against
guilts so to see accumulation taking
place taking place taking place
distribution taking place during the
European hours is
normal right here here
here you
know treasury bonds that was 10 years
here same thing in the bonds right
lesser volume in the
bonds but you're still getting nice
signals that's at 9 o' but you know
after nine here here here imagine this
was the only trade you took this day
from here to
here evening session here evening
session but European hours rather
here right day session on
Thursday okay this one one tick up this
one just went
sideways so anyway guys've gone for
about an hour here I'm going to take a
look at some questions I I don't want to
go on forever um Sunday morning but
there there are a lot of questions here
I do want to get to really
quick um
James James check your spam phon I know
I've sent it to you like
twice wa I know I've sent two general
emails but I thought I replied to your
email last night
but uh take a look in your spam folder
again you know I know Google
recently changed a lot same with Yahoo
mail even hot mail I
think is is
uh getting blocked nowadays with my
emails for some reason but
um take a look in your spam folder just
in case but I I'll respond to your email
again but I know I responded to it last
night but I'll take a look
um okay so let me see here questions uh
is the PC a session charart by bar
PC is by bar right every bar has a point
of control and point of control on a
footprint
chart in a bar is the price level with
the most volume it's on a bar by bar
basis as opposed to If you're looking at
a daily volume
profile that would be for the whole day
now you could break down your profiles
by minutes you know there's tools out
there that you could draw um a profile
box you know from say I want to draw
from here to here you know from this or
from the swing low to the swing High you
know you drop you just cover this and
it'll give you a point of control like
you know whatever um probably be down
here around 09 okay so basically the
period that you're looking at okay and
in this case I'm looking at it on a bar
by bar
basis um yeah it's looking at yeah he
yes about PLC swing it's not PLC swing
it's PLC wave but yeah it's looking on a
three bar basis um swing filter the
larger
number is stronger Simon asks well I
don't say it's stronger in a sense right
it's really what it's doing is it's
looking over a wider period so if your
swing period is five it's just looking
over a shorter period if you set it at
25 it's going to look over a longer
period so for
example if
I say this Market is
trading where am I
here okay let's go back to the end here
okay so this is where the market closed
on
Friday 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 18 19 20
21 22 23 24
25 if the swing filter was set
at
25 where's this vertical line F7 don't
use vertical lines that
much so if I wanted to know what the
swing high and swing low of this time
period is from
this blue line to the right to the end
of the chart well the swing low is going
to be here swing high is going to be
here for this period so the higher you
set it right the
more data you're looking at that's going
to be your swing low that's going to be
your swing high if you set it shorter to
you
know like here right last 10 bars I know
what this is that's about 10 this would
be your swing low right because you're
not looking at the swing low anymore
this is not going to be your swing high
this will be your swing
high but if you are looking at a period
from you
know here to here between these two bars
this would be your swing low this would
be your swing High okay so does it make
it stronger well in a
sense it's looking over a wider
period but your swing High swing low is
going to be different
yeah it says yeah it can be um a lot
more noise with time
base especially if you're looking at
momentum right if you're momentum Trader
you know you want to be looking at a
chart where it's really showing price
movement as opposed to time
movement so using a
um Range based chart might
be in your uh best
interest
well again you know sarm ask is it
better to use a Time based chart or
range based
chart again it depends on you
and and the market your trading right
again I
wouldn't use uh I got a let's go back
here right if I was looking at the wave
I I I still wouldn't use a wave on a
Time based chart
in the bonds or
tens I would still use it you know on a
range based chart because that's the
type of chart how I I use you know this
is bonds right so being beinging here
here you know that one didn't work out
this one didn't work out kind of worked
out kind of worked out kind of worked
out here you know previous days it's a
nice move here this is
in the Asian hours it goes one two ticks
higher here goes four five ticks lower
this was a nice move so again it
it it's going to vary on the market that
you're looking
at right because you say you're looking
at a market like
um okay so we'll start here real quick
with
uh well use meal for examples start on a
range based chart okay so you can see
here right you get a lot of this back
and forth right bullish bearish bullish
bearish bullish no
sorry
bullish
bearish bullish bullish bearish bullish
then the Run starts okay that's chop now
of course obviously if you're going to
use a
uh you know a big swing filter 10 or
something it would just show this one
take out this one you know some of
these if you're on a minute base
chart there any here there's one here a
bullish one here and where are you going
to get long is on the
breakout of the top of this wave where's
your stop going to be it's going to be
below that wave so maybe well you
wouldn't got stopped out here because it
didn't trade above until afterwards
right then you could have caught that
move
um you here right this is your low so
your high of the wave you're buying that
breakout really with the wave is you're
trying to get long on a breakout or get
short on a
breakdown okay obviously this one
started to break out then eventually
failed here well that's right before the
close um you know night session you're
not going to get much because it's it's
very
quiet again here right got your wave but
it's just sitting in inside the wave so
you're not going to take this
trade right I like to give it two bars
to sort of break
out you know but sometimes I use
three here it broke out broke down
immediately in the next bar you're
getting short 30 10
30 even again your stop is above the
high here you know
31 comes back up test that high and then
sells
off you know here's a breakout here's a
wave here right this one again next bar
inside you're getting short in here or
here okay it doesn't work out then you
got a bullish one all right then you
you close it you get getting long right
to catch this move people say ah you
know this why I laugh at people say who
trades me all well this move from
326 to 329 it's a $300 move right there
so
um is time base better it can be but
again it depends on
you um let's go burn through some more
questions
here Market weakness reads Delta Neon
asks
let just going just reading these
questions here NE ask uh again basically
Buy sell limit Market orders yeah that's
what's in the footprint
it's okay this is a question that came
up the other day and I know it's kind of
for people that are new to reading
orderflow right you hear of aggressive
Traders right passive Traders um
and for every trade to occur there is a
buyer and a seller right there's either
an aggressive buyer buying from a
passive seller or an aggressive seller
selling to a passive
buyer okay and you could read that
information in the footprint chart okay
so like even if there's you like here is
a selling a balance of 204 right it's on
the bid side there was a passive buyers
there that took all the aggressive
selling that was taking place they took
204 contracts before the passive buyers
gave up aggressive sellers still sold it
lower 57 contracts 1348 24 before the
aggressive
selling got overrun by the aggressive
buying to move the prices back up
okay ju
also asking for the link
okay well Peter asks what's indicator
gives the best results for S&P for
example to start
with well go to the default settings
that you
have look
for well this one I've got accumulation
distribution
um the the easiest one I recommend to
people it's easiest to see is the
abandoned value areas like
this this this this or sorry this one
this one um this one right because I
know the market is moving away from
value to me that's the easiest trades to
take
Dwight ask for the
link um Gord asks uh
so are you saying you you look for the
bar following the Delta Divergence with
the ratio well I'm looking for both
could either appear in the same bar both
Delta Divergence and the
ratio okay
that's sort of setup one but set up one
a is the
Divergence then in the next bar has the
ratio not the other way around not the
ratio and then the Divergence you're not
going to get that it's going to be the
Divergence and then next bar has the
bullish or bearish ratio so you're going
to have bullish or bearish Divergence
followed by
bullish ratio okay so if you have
bullish uh let's just go back here
um let me
just clean up this chart
here so turn off that
and ratios where are
you and I'll turn off the
wa so again we'll Market this this is
still meal
um I'm just looking for an example
here right you have your Divergence with
your bullish ratio so you have the gold
in here but even if this wasn't a
bullish ratio the bullish ratio came in
the next bar 48 you have your Divergence
and then the bullish ratio not where you
have the bullish Divergence than the
bearish ratio not that that's why I
wanted to make that clear um you
know let's go back to the day session
there's a little more
activity
so
again bearish well 745 is when it closes
then it reopens at 8:30 so you're not
going to really take a trade here at 739
going in four minutes but like this
bullish sorry bearish ratio bearish
Divergence um let me just you know
here see if there's another example in
here it'd be like this bullish
Divergence bullish ratio in this case it
just went
sideways hope that clears that up gourd
um do I look at higher time frame for
confirmation continuation no I look at
the chart I'm looking
at um Bala asks how do I identify the
price action which is going sideways
using orderflow data any key factors we
can
check on any of your indicators well the
easiest way to check if a market is
going
sideways it's one keep an eye on the
point of controls are they more or less
the same price level another way I like
to look at it is these value
areas are they
overlapping like here right overlapping
overlapping overlapping to me that's a
sign of a market going sideways or are
they starting steadily going lower okay
or higher
here like here here here but if it
generally they're if they're generally
covering the same prices to me that's a
sign of a market going
sideways that's a good
question your Miss also really guys um
so a lot of you just I'm G to send out
the links again for the upgrade version
for users but please check your spam
folder
um
Anthony I'm just looking at your
question
Anthony the license token
um s Simon asks
um about the strategy analyzer and the
orror software you know I I don't use
the strategy analyzer
but I you know because that question
came up the other day um I'm gonna ask
my programmer about that he would know
better than me so I think he's more
again I'm a neoy when it comes to
programming stuff I'm a bit old school
even in trading I'm a pointand click guy
but for me the most automation I use is
uh
markers
um neon ask how long until the actual
signal generates when a signal is shown
well when the bar is open if the order
flow is there so for
example right like this bar here okay
market is closed
obviously when the point of control is
right here obviously if this Market is
open and it's still trading the point of
control can move once the bar closes all
you know whatever signal whatever is
there is there it's set it's not going
to
change veto asks are you teaching all
this in your course of courses um no
this is just a special uh training this
is outside of that stuff I mean you
know I teach a lot of orderflow stuff in
in the courses but uh you know this is
just sort
of you know I want to talk about how
these new tools can help you cuz you
know some of these tools open POC I talk
about in the course es who just haven't
had them in the software you just have
to have to look at the chart yourself
and now you have it on the chart being
plotted for you so you don't have to
determine is this an open POC or is this
a
wave does the orderflow
trader is ready to use without the
external data supplier kinetic and an
nt8 demo well you need a data feed
Alexander asks you definitely need a
data feed it's not going to work without
data right and you need a real time
you're trading obviously you need a
real-time data
feed the most efficient effective way to
get a real-time data feed at a low cost
is open an account with Ninja Trader
trade tell them you're going to trade
micros right you can open accounts for
250 bucks because if you pay for a
real-time data feed from someone like
kinetic just the CME data alone is going
to cost you 125 bucks if you have an
account and it's funded like a real
account
at a broker like ninja trade brokerage
they
will get you the
data at a reduced price it's um and it's
a data feed that you can trade off of
kinetics data feed you can't trade off
of that because it doesn't go anywhere
it's one way where you need a two-way
connection to the exchange if you're
going to
trade but like I've got level one level
two data you don't need level two for a
footprint on CME CBT NX Co X um and your
X I pay like $66 a month for Real Time
level one level two if it was level one
I'd proba I'd be paying you know maybe
50 bucks a month but if you're going to
get data from an outside data vendor
real-time data feed you're going to pay
for CME then you're going to pay for
cbot you're going to pay for NYX you're
going to pay for comx and whatever other
exchanges you want to look at and it's
going to add up really fast you we
talking hundreds of dollars so the most
effective way is just open an account
and it'll just get debited from your
account
um Lynn ask is there a way to change the
right
margin you're talking about this area
here right like that you really just got
to scroll
um I thought there used to be a way I
don't I forgot how to get it I'd have to
look it up but even that I've noticed
sometimes on some of these things like
with
Ninja sometimes these things just Auto
default um but anyway I'll look into
that Lynn I I
don't I thought there used to be a way I
think on seven where you could set a
default setting for this right
margin but on E I'm not sure
hey Vlad Vlad says it was in his spam
um okay Thomas um it's weird because
again I'm going to send it out after
this presentation Gord ask have you ever
found a good indicator for a higher time
frame set up the lower
entries
um there are some Gord I want to talk
about that probably on the weekly
session because that that's a little bit
more that'll take me a while to talk
about but
um I'll take a look at that
s about I see your question there
s about your license
token get that sorted out for you
uh yeah actually the
L it says about uh oh Richard ver says
the website is a secure website so I
mean it's got the authentication all
that but the software is safe Richard um
Lou
just a doubt to ninja Trader if I want
to draw an area in the chart between two
prices in the footprint chart how do I
guarantee the footprint comes on
top of the drawing I'm not being able to
do it within the area the footprint goes
to the
back uh so you want to draw an area on
the chart between two prices in the
footprint chart L
um not sure I'm understanding your
question I kind of understand your
question but
um our footprint chart is
actually our footprint is actually dra
uh programmed to
appear at the back at the bottom you
know if there was imagine if there was
layers um L send me an email cuz I I
have talked to my program that that's
kind of a
separate thing
um because you want yours to appear on
the top because the problem is right
there's been some tools that I use from
you know I I have a lot of tools from
Ninja caters because I I partnered with
them on a lot of stuff so they gave me
like a lot of access to their stuff and
you know I'm always testing out other
tools
and sometimes some tools from third
party vendors would always draw to the
back and it wouldn't show up on my
footprint chart so I had my programmer
go in
and set our footprint to appear on the
very bottom so anything on top of it
right if you were to add an extra
indicator would appear on
top but Lou so you're sort of asking
sort of something that can do the
opposite um so shoot me an email on
that um Neer okay see your email
there
Walter yeah it is free Walter is asking
about
uh if the upgrade is
free excuse me sorry for existing users
yes it is
free um Santos ask about Ninja ranko
bars
um okay I don't have nzo Reno but uh
I'll reach out to them see if I get a
copy uh Chris asks PLC wave with ex
Prince of R2 seems to be a high
probability trade
setup yeah Christian
um yeah there so many different again I
could go on I mean that's the beauty of
it right of the software is there's a
lot of different tools again think of
it I say like a Swiss army knife is was
one way
but like you you go to a buffet you know
a restaurant right there's a lot of
things out there you're not going to get
everything I mean some people do but uh
you know me I always
check what's the meat you know is the
crab legs I go for that um first right
so I'm going to use the ones that I like
to use you know just as you would eat
the meals you like to eat um but then
you can find you know combinations you
know mashed potatoes and gravy you know
Delta breakout and and something think
or exhaustion prints and um you know
Divergence or as Chris says PC
wave because again you know you don't
have to worry about it because everybody
looks at orderflow differently all right
so not you're not going to get millions
and and not everybody uses orderflow
people you go Kicking and Screaming
sometimes into
orderflow um Richard I don't use algo
and orderflow 7 on the same chart um I
use them on different ones I use I just
throw the algo on a on a simple bar
chart which is easier for me
because I'm looking at certain things
taking place with the
algo the blue Daniel asks
um when does the Blue Line Print after
one bar closes yeah it'll print
actually
things hang on here I'm just writing
something down here so like for example
like like the as soon as this ratio like
in this bar as this bar is forming as
soon as this ratio is taking
place it will print as long as the
Overflow stays
there okay if this bar turns
red it's not going to print as a blue
line or you know or bullish ratio then
it'll start analyzing the ratio from the
top side of the bar
okay Alan asks will the
setups be added to the Vault um no it's
different want ask uh what confluences
signal have you tested with these news
indicators between them or existent
well
like okay so just go back to these
indicators real quick
the a lot of these you know the ex
existing indicators I still use them
right but we've one of the things
that not like I hate to call it secret
sauce but I've always told people you
got to look at these
things in context of the market right
anything in context of the market
so right so I'd always look I always
like to trade around the edges of the
market meaning highs or lows or swing
highs or swing lows that's why it was
important to get this swing period on
here so if I'm looking for um you know
an exhaustion print what is this Mark so
this is meal I don't know i' probably
use a small number three
right if I'm looking for
exhaustion in the
market right I'm going to be looking for
it to come after a
move
to me that's going to give me a
potential for a
reversal and it was hard for me to get
traders to understand why you'd be
looking for
exhaustion at a swing high or swing
low because they're like well why you
I'm like well if you're looking for
exhaustion imagine you're running a race
you're not going to get exhausted in the
first 10 meters something people might
nowadays I might but you know after your
run for a half a mile that's when you're
going to get start feeling exhausted
just as if a market is making a move
right where you going to look for
exhaustion after the move has taken
place right for a potential
reversal so to me that that's like the
most biggest thing
here want to ask uh to automate it yeah
we're going to probably get something
going on about
that
Francis say uh okay Francis I'll check
for your
email
but I didn't see it either
um yeah the session is recorded
Peter arene thanks
um Steve asked for
NQ okay got some time
here now I'll be honest though NQ is not
a market that I I look at NQ but I don't
I haven't traded this Market
in a long time just it's just it just
moves too much for me um
I prefer markets that
uh are a little bit
more easier to read the order flow right
and to be honest I don't even look at it
on a one minute chart what I do look at
it is on a on a 30- second chart
now with this Market you know people
always ask you know what are you going
to look for well you can start with you
know a lot of the same things you see
these are the divergences here that are
set up now this is and see the
exhaustion print here here but it's not
like I'm looking at anything super out
of the ordinary right I I would look at
the value areas see what value areas are
doing um you know are they
being abandoned so I keep them until
tested but you know I just sort of you
know and to be honest in a market like
inq Prim Point controls don't play that
big a role um just because the bars are
kind of wide
but I'd be looking for these abandoned
value areas like this again you know
people always ask what's the best setup
well the easiest setup to see is very
visual is the abandoned value an area
that's not traded into in the next bar
just say this one this one this
one right here here here here
here here
here
um iene again thanks uh Johnny also says
software is wonderful
um thean asks uh in your experience do
you have noticed any setups with
indicators that tend to work well when
looking to trade
gold I'm new to all this and just
looking for some insight well gold
Gold's a nice Market actually um for
trading because you tend to get a lot of
size go through it out of nowhere size
just comes in but this is uh let's go
back to minute base chart start there
minute base chart is always a good
starting point
um simple thing right the value areas
the value areas then you can start
adding you know here's a
Divergence with you know an exhaustion
print again same one that I had on on
the previous charts right I don't need
to start adding on you know real
different stuff unless I want to um okay
so let's take off but value are is is a
great tool I think more Traders should
use it um we'll take off the uh exhaus
and print take off Delta we'll use the
accumulation distribution I'll just
leave it as swing filter off and passive
traders in control see how that turns
out right you see accumulation
accumulation accumulation accumulation
right as this Market just keeps running
up on
Friday right some distribution okay you
know people say oh you got such a small
move yeah we just ran up you know 20
bucks maybe there some profit taking
more accumulation more
accumulation you know that's on a one
minute you know people Gord was asking
about you know longer time frames I'll
be honest for me a longer time frame on
Border flow is 5 minutes if you'd
consider that long but same thing you
going to look for accumulation
accumulation accumulation the value area
right that's not traded into I mean if
you're trading a 5 minute chart during
the day session value area that's not
traded into you drop from 60 down to
almost 50 then on the way back
up again from 60
70 right all the way up to 80s
90s okay and you can see the
accumulation on the way up here these
dark blue lines that are not traded I
mean almost every bar here on the way
Up's got accumulation taking
place
accumulation moves up
Distribution on the moves down so as you
get
higher right then you might start seeing
some signs of dist contribution here
here all right going into the close I
mean it's normal this you know after you
have a big run up to start seeing
distribution come in especially going
into the close it's one o'clock here
right and this Market just more or less
goes sideways a little bit lower into
the
close Emanuel ask will this video be
available of yep it will be
um well it says
uh by the way upgrading to the latest NT
software NT
upgrades you must have been on a way
earlier version W
um remember last spring I think they
came out with the the
8.1 because I on my older
PC you know the one that I use for like
email and surfing the internet and stuff
I still got 8.
0.28 on there and the overl trader won't
work on
there 8.1 has been out for a year and a
over a year now about a
year and it's gone through several
iterations already so you I'll be honest
you the first six months I hated it but
yeah you have to get updated on it
unfortunately but if you're doing the
the
upgrade n
software you should you're not going to
need your all you need is your login
credentials right the templates if
you're going to use the
software door fil trator 7 you got to
create new template
anyway okay so again if you want to use
it I mean it's unfortunate you have to
right and you again I can't do anything
about it because if you're on the older
version of orderflows Trader or sorry of
n Trader and you add this new version of
orderflows Trader it's not going to work
it's going to cause your system to hang
because there's
functions it's doing things it's trying
to look for certain functions on the
older version of ninja Trader that just
aren't there right so of course it's not
going to work it's going to cause it to
hang anyway and you think you know
there's nothing more frustrating than
trying to open in because I went through
that I went through that we months ago
my program like it's not working
that's because I had the older version
up or the older template up and it's
trying to access stuff that's just not
there to access and it would cause it to
hang so it's unfortunate but it it has
to be
done Luciana says yeah ninja Trader data
is $12 a month for level
one all right everyone I'm going to uh
I'll end it
there um
so again you know have a thanks for
coming out you know it's Sunday morning
you know it's a big ask I said I sort of
sprung this on you the last 24 hours I'm
going to do this so I appreciate you're
sticking through to the end um on a
Sunday so have a great week
everybody and again I'm going to go
through again all these questions I see
I got James Juan Dwight Ur
miss everybody asking for the I'll email
it out again to you guys but again I'll
try to email you guys separately maybe
I'll send it off from my uh personal
email maybe that will go through for
some reason sometimes it works sometimes
it doesn't but have a great uh rest of
your weekend everybody and uh you know
if you can make it on the if you if you
have the software and you're on the list
for the uh weekly trainings on Wednesday
uh be sure to uh make it out there all
right everyone have a great weekend
catch you later
byebye